the Western world has collapsed in real  time and it's a failed society and one  of the reasons is a failed Society is  because of the over sexualization  especially of females as a whole if a  woman comes up to me and goes I'll be  the best sex you ever had I am [ __ ]  revolted I don't want the best sex I've  ever had I want you to be pure and a  virgin you shouldn't know what sex is  cook my [ __ ] dinner shut up don't  come and talk to me about [ __ ]  sucking dick it's vile it's disgusting I  don't want to hear that [ __ ] can I say  something I don't want to hear that [ __ ]  what I want is a woman that makes me  look good no woman who's running around  talking about sucking dick can make me  look good so I lose interest completely  and utterly and that's the truth so what  she's saying is completely correct these  are old school things but it's not about  the ACT yes you can order food of course  it's about the status that comes with it  that's what it's about